good morning Hank it's Tuesday so I
think one of the great unanswered
questions of world history is why cities
like for 95 percent of human history
basically everyone was a hunter-gatherer
living in a small band of maybe a few
dozen people and then around 12,000
years ago community started to get
bigger with the advent of Agriculture
and domesticated livestock suddenly one
person could harvest and/or slaughter
more than one person's food needs
meaning that not everyone had to be in
the food acquisition business and that
allowed for specialization of Labor
professional priests and scribes and
soldiers and so on but how and why that
happened is the subject of much debate
among historians not least because the
shift from hunting and gathering to
agriculture seems to have been
completely irrational
for starters hunter-gatherers seemed to
have been healthier than early
agriculturalists like analysis of human
remains and archaeological sites show us
that famine and starvation were much
more common among early settlement
dwellers also hunter-gatherers were less
likely to die of disease pandemics
because you know cities meant lots of
people living together and getting each
other sick and also living with
livestock so diseases could cross the
species barrier so living in early
agricultural settlements was bad for
your health it also probably meant more
work like Studies of 20th century
hunting and gathering communities showed
that members of those communities work
on average less than 20 hours per week
acquiring food and also less than 20
hours per week on so-called domestic
labor which is everything from preparing
food to tool and shelter maintenance
everything we can gather about early
agricultural life is that it was a lot
more labor-intensive and certainly
contemporary life is a lot more
labor-intensive like Americans for
instance work on average 40 hours a week
and spend another 36 hours per week on
domestic labour so why would anyone want
to live in a city where your life is
harder but also shorter well there are
many theories about this some people
think the chicken of state power came
first at like the moment there was a
surplus it was taxed by the state and
then the power structure became
inescapable for the people living under
it others think the egg came first that
people chose to use the surplus to
create a state that could protect them
from outside attack some theorized that
then as now cities were just more
exciting places to live with more
connections to make others argue the
relative quality of hunter-gatherer
communities was unattractive to those
who wanted power and that the drive to
concentrate power drove the growth of
cities but whatever happened it does
seem like cities were not in these short
or even
term interest of those who lived in them
now it'd be easy to say and many have
that this was all a mistake and we
should have just remained
hunter-gatherers certainly agriculture
and the ensuing human centric planet has
been very bad for biodiversity on earth
but we also shouldn't romanticise pre
agricultural communities where
infanticide was usually common and rates
of death by violence were usually much
higher than they are now
and while settlements do seem to have
been initially disastrous for those who
lived in them they did eventually lead
to better lives for humans by almost any
measure we are less likely to die of
infectious disease or malnutrition or
violence than ever and while as I
mentioned earlier we do work more than
hunter-gatherers we also work less than
we have at any point in the last 150
years meanwhile absolute poverty is
declining dramatically and median US
household income is at its highest point
ever but I'd actually argue the greatest
benefit of cities has been reading and
writing which have allowed us to speed
our accumulation of knowledge and fuel
discoveries and science and technology
and which could only be invented in big
communities with specialization of labor
but there were trade-offs to the choices
our ancestors made and there are
trade-offs to the choices we're making
today toget intentionally I think you
have to bear in mind what you believe to
be the ground of meaning in life like if
the point of life is to preserve
biodiversity on our home planet than
hunting and gathering is the way to go
if the point is to seek an understanding
of the universe and our place in it then
specialization of Labor is a necessity
but I have to say that while I
understand much has been lost I am
grateful to live in a world with
telescopes and vaccines and YouTube and
books late update speaking of books Hank
I am so incredibly excited you are
publishing a book next to your fancy New
York Times article when the doobly-doo
below I continue to be awed by your
ability to do so many things so well it
is an absolutely remarkable thing that
is the title but it's also how I feel
Hank I'll see you on Friday